this video is proudly sponsored by
Squarespace
training is a never-ending process
through exercise recovery and nutrition
we aim to improve some aspects of
ourselves but the work is never done few
of us will ever feel that we've reached
a point where we don't need to be any
stronger or any faster or any more
flexible
the goal then is simply to stay on that
path and to keep progressing so as not
to plateau
at some point on this journey if we stay
the course we will reach our own Peak
Performance the best we could have
achieved without given circumstances
but how do you do this how do you keep
getting stronger and smarter and more
agile even in the face of challenges
ultimately this comes down to mindset
and strategy
this is your ultimate form so giftedness
has nothing to do with it likewise this
is often what separates the top
performers and athletes as much as
physical ability
how do you keep striving even in the
face of defeat how do you avoid
stagnation
it starts with an honest appraisal of
where you are now and where you want to
be this is where eager can get in the
way it's tempting to focus only on your
strengths and to overlook the glaring
gaps in your Fitness this is how many of
us operate
if you're extremely strong that you
can't touch your toes then the priority
should be touching your toes not adding
another five kilograms onto your bench
press unless your competitive power
lifter if you get out of breath climbing
the stairs that's a good thing to focus
on next sometimes this might mean taking
a step back from other aspects of your
training letting things slide if only a
little right now I need to focus on
repairing and fortifying my back that
means I have to take a step back from
some of the goals I previously set for
myself it's hard to see myself move
backwards in those areas but ultimately
it's very much worth it this is a
marathon and not a Sprint
I know I've said this many times before
but training in a cross-modal manner is
one of the key ways to develop yourself
as an all-rounder ignoring things that
don't appeal to you as much will
ultimately leave you with glaring
weaknesses that could become a problem
in real life you might not care about
Mobility now but if you don't focus on
it at all it will only get worse it will
dramatically shorten your athletic
career
next we must adopt the mindset of
shoshin what is shoshin is a concept
from Karate that Jesse encamp talks
about a lot Jesse has a brilliant
YouTube channel that I highly recommend
everyone check out so shoshin translates
roughly to beginner's mind and
essentially means approaching every
scenario as a beginner with much to
learn rather than as someone with
pre-established ideas trying to show off
what a big shot they are and in honesty
it's a superpower this is why when
visiting another Dojo it's polite for a
karate car that's a karate student to
wear a white belt it demonstrates that
they are here to learn and that their
novices at least in the context of that
school
you could think of approaching YouTube
channels in the same way
there's nothing to gain from showing off
but if you listen with an open mind
there is always something new to learn
even from someone with far less
experience than you training in a way
you might not understand or agree with
even from someone you might not
necessarily like
as Bruce Lee would say empty your cup
I've grown so much as a trainer and a
fitness writer by listening and learning
from other people all of them have
helped me to see new ways to improve and
to provide me with more tools for my
training toolbox you can be defensive
and stay just where you are or you can
keep growing ultimately the one Keen to
demonstrate their expertise will be left
in the dust
learn to focus only on the things you
can control
this is a big mindset shift that can
help you to combat anxiety improve your
performance and ultimately overcome your
limitations
too often we spend time worrying about
things that we have no control over
going into a competition we might worry
about it raining or about the skill of
the opponent none of this is helpful so
instead we should be laser focused on
what is within our control our diet our
training and our mindset
likewise it's no good me wishing right
now that I didn't have a bad back I do
what's in my control is how I train
going forwards this tip came from the
book Chasing excellence and I absolutely
believe it's a key to steady forward's
progress
train harder than last time as coach
Greg would say and this is such good
advice because it simplifies Progressive
overload perfectly logging every single
workout and having precise targets and
goals is all good and well but
ultimately it's a fragile approach that
leaves little room for improvisation
but if you simply train the best you can
on that day every time you work out you
will gradually see yourself improve
it doesn't matter how but as long as
you're pushing yourself you will keep
growing
set yourself rules and systems these are
superior to goals in many ways often
goals include too many aspects that are
outside of our control if once again we
want to focus on the things we can
control and creating rules like I will
go to the gym X number of times a week
or systems such as set ways to train can
be far more effective and again you'll
see the results add up over time
but train smarter it's not just about
training harder although that is part of
it it's also learning as you go finding
what works for you and staying curious
reading about your training discovering
new training methods and learning about
the human body I can spend less time in
the gym because I understand the precise
amount of stimulus I need to trigger
growth and I know how it feels this
comes from years of training and because
I know bang for your buck exercises that
pack multiple benefits into a single
move moreover My Endless research and
fascination with the topic of human
performance has helped me to find new
ways to train to find new goals even the
completely expanded my comprehension of
what's possible
and be adaptable along the way you will
run into obstacles whether it's an
injury a change of location or a new
commitment how you respond to those
challenges is what matters think of
plotting a course for a set destination
our goal you know where you want to go
now the challenge is getting there so
you draw a straight line from where you
are now to where you want to be but what
if you come across an obstacle a sheer
Cliff or a sudden drop
well you go around being adaptable means
you can go around the challenge it might
take longer but you're still on track
this is your journey your story like I
said not a race a marathon don't see
these setbacks as roadblocks see them as
part of the adventure
so I hope you found this video useful
and interesting guys if you did then
leave a like and share it around let me
know what your tips for achieving your
Peak Performance are if you're looking
for a training program that incorporates
multiple different training modality
that aims to improve everything from max
strength to Mobility to endurance to
even brain function then check out my
ebook and training program super
functional training 2.0 that comes with
an 80 plus page ebook and over two hours
of instructional video there's a link to
that in the description down below
[Music]
either way guys thank you so much for
watching this one and I'll see you next
time
bye for now
another way to be smarter when working
towards goals is to choose the right
tools and if it's building a website or
promoting your business that you're
interested in then Squarespace today's
sponsor is one of the very best tools
Squarespace makes creating a website as
easy as possible thanks to a huge number
of Highly modern and customizable
templates you can build the foundation
of a website in minutes from there there
are a huge variety of powerful features
that Empower you to grow as far as your
business needs the sky's the limit and
that's why Squarespace Powers so many of
the biggest brands on the web you'll be
able to build a community and generate
Revenue with members only gated content
you can manage that Community with
useful tools or build it with fully
integrated commenting systems with
threaded comments replies and likes
creating content is simple too thanks to
the powerful blogging tools that include
formatting categorizing posts scheduling
and more you can even connect to your
social media so that posts are shared
automatically through your site those
looking to build their business further
can use extensive e-commerce
capabilities and if you need more you
can add more features to Squarespace
itself using a host of third-party
plugins including Inventory management
marketing streamlined bookkeeping sales
tax reconciliation global Shipping and
more go to squarespace.com to find out
more and when you're ready to get
started go to squarespace.com forward
slash bioneer to get 10 off the purchase
of your first domain or website thanks
again to Squarespace thanks to you guys
for sticking around and bye for now